the really important thing there is as a
leader or as a head coach you need to
know yourself when we're a young coach
coming through we think we know
everything and we think we can do
everything and the longer your case the
more you realise know your strengths
coach to your strengths and then bring
other people in that compliment
supplement and add to the team
environment
eddie jones welcome michelle
uh nice to meet you mate really glad to
have you here so why write a book on
leadership at all do you want the world
to have better leaders in it or are you
trying to synthesize what you learned
what was the compulsion to do it
well uh on the back of the last book
macmillan approached me during the
lockdown to do a book on leadership and
i'd always thought
there was a couple of books when i was
growing up as a coach learning my trade
that i really
appreciated the help i got from one was
from pat riley the la lakers uh winner
within and the other one was bill walsh
from the san francisco 49ers which i
think is called winning edge
and i thought well maybe if i can put
down some of the thoughts that i've had
in in my career might help some young
aspiring coach coming through to to help
them in in their difficult way of
learning how to be a coach
why do you think it is such a difficulty
why is leadership such a fine skill to
attune
uh well i think you know
coaching as as i do for a living
it appears easy but it's such a complex
convoluted
um ever demanding profession where
you're dealing with
you know young athletes who increasingly
want to be more individual which is the
way the world is
and you're trying to put them together
in the one team and do the same thing in
that in a period of time and and
and they extract from them effort that
they don't normally want to give
does that suggest that it's becoming a
bit more difficult to be a leader or be
a coach now it sounds like people are
becoming more individualistic which is
making coordination more challenging
uh look i don't think it's become more
difficult i i just think it's there's
more parts to it now um
you have to take into consideration a
lot more things than previously you had
to just for instance
you know within coaching a team you have
to take a lot of consideration into the
the learning environment we which you
create for the players yeah whereas
previously you know if you look back 20
or 30 years ago you could stand at the
front of the room
and say this what we're going to do and
everyone will say well how much how much
how hard you want us to do it coach and
now you have to explain why you have to
do it you have to make sure you have the
right number of messages you have to
have the messages in the right way you
have to have the right uh right sort of
visual presentation for the players
so all of that's become become more
challenging um to
to extract the maximum effort from the
players
how do you balance that need for team
members to listen to your instructions
but them to also come up with their own
solutions i think you've got a story in
the book about when you presented one of
the players with sort of a here's a
problem you need to fix it but also the
players still need to listen to your
words how do you find that balance
yeah well increasingly chris it's more
about the players finding their own
solutions i think
coaches are more facilitators now and
what what we need to be really good at
though is is setting the standards of
performance and making those
uh performance standards very clear for
everyone but then guiding the player to
where they need to go to achieve those
standards rather than commanding the
players to do it
um that's interesting
what or when do you think that you're at
your best are you at your absolute best
now as a leader
uh well i think you never get there mate
i think you're always
chasing us like that elusive dream it's
that
that pie in the sky type thing we're
always trying to become a better
a a better coach and a better leader you
know we had uh roy hodgson come and
visit us
uh during the last six nations and yeah
roy's 72 he's coached i think four
different countries uh most of the top
football clubs in the world and you know
his opening statement was so boys i'm
still trying to work out how to be a
good catch and i think that's so true
that you're always chasing to be a
little bit better because
you know there is no
finite state in sport and there is no
finite state in any high performance
organization yeah there's always what's
coming next who's who's chasing you but
he's trying to do a little bit better
than you
what are the values of a good leader to
you you break that down into a sort of a
big five how do you go through courage
hard work discipline iron will and
curiosity
uh well i think all of those things are
important and they're all important at
various times i think
as a as i spoke about in the book
there's a cycle of performance that you
need to go through where you need to
build up the team and particularly at
the start when you take over a team i
think you need a lot of courage
to come up with a vision that's probably
higher than the players have ever wanted
to achieve
and then you've got to sell that vision
to the players
you've got to make sure that they're
prepared to work hard to to achieve that
vision and that message has got to be
fresh all the time because you know the
more you can
you can repeat the message the more
chance you've got people are believing
it you know that's the one thing that's
that's very consistent we were lucky
enough uh recently to get doug lemof in
um who's uh
a school teacher in the usa um
and he started a a
a number of schools called uncommon
schools and he's basically set up
schools in the most
underprivileged areas in in the cities
of america
and created this fantastic learning
environment where kids are doing
significantly better than the norms for
their areas so we got him into to create
uh
to get the t to get our coaches to learn
more about being better teachers rather
than just being coaches because that's
what it is now it's teaching the players
you know guiding them
sometimes telling them and most of the
time trying to create the environment
for them to learn by themselves
is there an insight that was surprising
to you when learning
what he does or was this something that
you realize that you were doing
incorrectly
it's not as
as severe as that but what it is it's
the it's the nuances of getting the
message through like he did this
presentation on rugby and he doesn't
know he doesn't know anything about
rugby but there's this presentation and
our coaching sat there
our coaching team sat there in awe about
his ability to to capture the
information succinctly
put it into a way that that most people
can remember it
so it's that understanding of how the
brain operates understanding then how
you how you
create that that right message for the
players so they're able to remember what
you're doing and just some of the things
you know
like if you want the team to do a
tactical
if you want a team to follow a tactical
area of the game that need to practice
at least four times during the week the
brain
the brain won't take that unless you do
it four times and if it's more of a
message if you haven't repeated that
message at least seven times during the
week the chances again of the players
being able to remember that message is
is
is uh not great
those little things are really important
yeah the value of repetition from
someone who doesn't have a clue about
rugby but was able to come over and give
people who've spent their entire lives
doing rugby some new news
yeah and a survey of repetition without
having repetition yeah that's the
important thing because if we keep
repeating the same message and you keep
saying it the same way people get bored
of you know and and particularly in
today's society where you know if you
haven't got a new something new on your
podcast people don't come back to it do
they you know because there's always
something new they can go to you look at
you know soft drinks or drinks in the in
the shops now like 30 years ago you had
fan of coke lemonade and water probably
and now you've got you know each week
there's a new flavor a new
sparkling you know lemon
yuzu whatever it is juice coming out
because people want new things and it's
the same when you're giving messages to
players now if you keep saying the same
thing
uh they'll
they won't listen to you so you've got
to present the same message in a number
of different ways so it's that idea of
having repetition without repetition the
same as coaching on the field you know
the importance of fundamentals in any of
the games we play whether it be football
whether it be american football whether
it be rugby union the fundamentals are
the other bit that gives you the beauty
of the game
but young players don't want to do
the endless drills of passing the ball
without thinking so you've got to be
able to create those drills
that are repetition but at the same time
the players think that they're doing
something new all the time
so there's a an element of novelty that
delivers the same message that you've
wanted to get across to them
100 might stand to that beautiful and
you am i right in saying that you said
for physical activities you're looking
at four times a week and for
what does messages mean is that more
kind of like philosophies and theories
seven times within
all the message about about how we're
going to play just that
that key tactical message that you want
to stick in the head if you're not
repeating that seven times during the
week the chances of the players
remembering that is uh
is not great
that's interesting i wonder whether
i wonder whether the immersive element
that you get when players turn
professional or when they go to an
international stage i'm wondering how
much more of a benefit those players are
seeing because they're living and
breathing it think about the step change
between a club level player who maybe is
only with his team what once or twice
during the week and then again on game
day and then as this perhaps young
player works up and up not only does he
get better but his ability to get better
increases so much more because he's
starting to hit this critical mass of
messaging opportunities with the
coaching staff that he works with
yeah and i also think it's the ability
to learn and and
yeah you see that players who go from
one level to the to the next
um
their ability to learn quickly is is one
of the most distinguishing factors like
i know in english cricket they had a
theory that if a player went from county
to test cricket and within the first
three innings and test cricket he wasn't
able to get 50 the chance of him
adapting and being a really good player
is is quite
quite low um and i think that's so true
in most sports you see when a young
player goes up to the next level
if they adapt really quickly and that's
their ability to learn if they're able
to do that their chance of being
successful players far higher than that
player who's slow to adapt that's
interesting so it's like a uh
like a stress test
at very very high levels of pressure
this person's put into a new environment
new new stress is put upon them how do
they adapt and grow and learn and that
adaptability is um
a scalable insight that works out how
effective they're going to be over time
yeah yeah and and and the other part of
that is that they've got to have an open
mindset you know they've got to be open
to learning and they've got to have an
element of curiosity and they've also
got to be humble mate because
you know the hard thing for for players
particularly is to understand sometimes
they think they've made it they've got
to the next level so why do i have to
improve now and if you're humble you
always want to improve and you see with
the really great players you know you
look at federer you know he's he's what
he's 40 odd now and he's still got a
tennis catch
because he wants to improve and every
time he comes back for a new season he's
got a new stroke or variation of his
stroke
imagine if like every team sport player
had that approach to their game that
every off season they develop a new part
of their game by themselves and come
back with a new string of their bow and
the and the really good players do that
and not so good players think they've
made it and they and they don't think
they've got to keep improving
is there a tension between the
hard work and the iron will and the
discipline
and the curiosity that
those first three are
to do with kind of drilling and
iterating on what you already do and the
curiosity is on growing so you kind of
have this exploit and then this explore
element that there's two things going on
is there is there a tension that you
find between those
yeah oh it's a constant battle mate the
way you've said it is is right and
there's this constant battle in terms of
coaching whether you're supporting or
challenging the player so you've always
got this and with your environment
you've got the constant
battle or tension between being
comfortable because you need them to be
comfortable sometimes you know if you
keep pushing all the time
they get too uncomfortable but then when
they they start sitting comfortably on
the chair then you've got to make sure
you you make them a bit more
uncomfortable so
you know in terms of high performance
environment that's one of the things you
constantly appraising that support
challenge that that comfortable
uncomfortable set
that
sitting and moving you're always
appraising where you need to be and
trying to find the right way to keep
moving forward
how do you avoid burnout both for
yourself and for the
players i know that you're someone who
in the past has uh
how would you say push the limits of
this um
to its
to up towards its uh absolute peak
yeah well i think the first thing is
you've got to keep loving it you know if
you love if you really love something it
means a lot to you don't get burnt out
because
the passion's there the desires there
the enthusiasm there and it's you know i
never feel like
i've i'm doing a job i always feel like
i'm doing something i love doing um
and and that's why i'm still able to
catch it at 61
because it's not a job to me it's it's
something i love doing um
and i think the mistake i made when i
was a younger coach was that i expected
everyone else players and and assistant
coaches to have that same desire to want
to be like that all the time but as i've
got older and got more experience i've
i've understood that yeah everyone's got
their own way of doing it and sometimes
they might manifest itself in this
strong desire but they've still got the
desire there so it's being more having
more empathy about the way other people
do their job
it wouldn't work for everyone to have
your approach either right let's say
that you are the
uh bazooka or you're the hammer that
sees everything as a nail you don't need
that sometimes you need other people
that are more creative that are more
relaxed i know that you've got a lot of
women that are contributing as parts of
your coaching staff now that also add a
total different perspective into this
too
yeah well i think you know the the
recent period of time has shown how
important diversity is in life you know
not that anyone thought it wasn't but i
think that's really reinforced and i
think in the sporting environment it's
become even more important to understand
how important diversity is and and and
that and that
respect's almost more important than
harmony in a team organization i think
having the respect of diversity respect
of different opinions respect to
people's backgrounds respect of gender
all of that all of that is just so
important to an environment now well the
bottom line is it's not diversity for
diversity's sake either
the reason that it works is that you get
an effective outcome that you have a
team that performs better that's more
effective
oh 100 because everyone thinks the same
way everyone behaves the same way yeah
you don't get any new thoughts you don't
get any
creative conflict you need to have that
diversity to keep the keep the ball
moving um talk to me about when you
arrived to england in 2015 then how do
you begin
changing the direction
of a team when you're a brand new leader
you're this fresh behind the face sort
of guy that no one has an existing
relationship with but many people may
have pre-conceived ideas about
where'd you go
uh well i probably
learned the most
but just tell a little story about how i
approached it being a casual teacher or
being a supply teacher as they called it
in england
i did that for the first couple of years
when i became a teacher because there
wasn't any full-time jobs
so i'd go to a school and i used to go
to my old school and
and the classes you got were always the
tough classes because teachers don't
take days off when they got the top
students they take days off
they've got the the rat bag so i'd have
the bottom bottom class of year nine
boys you know when the hormones are
pumping through their bodies they they
know everything they don't want to be
told anything by a teacher and i quickly
learn out you know when you have those
guys maybe four or five times
a day
um you've got to quickly work out right
who's who's going to
who's going to be difficult for you and
you have to find some way to
some way to establish a relationship
who's going to help you
and again you have to find a
relationship with and then you have to
make the the content of your lesson
interesting
that that makes them want to be part of
the lesson so when you go to a new team
it's no different you know you've got to
try to find the players who you think
you need but maybe going to be difficult
and find a way to establish a
relationship quickly with them
work out the players who are going to be
with you from the start because they're
driven
make sure they understand your
philosophy
and where you want to go and then create
a training program that's interesting
that makes the players want to be there
um
and so you do that process you know and
when you're with the england side you've
got five days to do that before you play
a game so it's you know you got to get
on your horse and you got to do it
quickly
talk to me about how you
um bridge the gap between the difficult
ones and how you encourage and utilize
the motivation of the driven ones have
you got any strategies around how you
approach that
yeah well you've gotta you've gotta for
the difficult ones the difficult ones
are difficult usually for a reason
they're either
they're either really high performing
players which most of them are or
they're players you've got to get rid of
so you quickly got to make it you you
know if they're high performing players
they're difficult for a reason so you've
got to try to find out what they really
value
um what drives them like yeah i think
i've spoken before about james haskell
they've always been this muscular player
but never really performed for england
but i've met him a few times socially
before that in japan and i knew that
yeah he wanted to be loved so
you know some of the most overtly
ostentatious
out there type players that the players
are the most
insecure
so i immediately um had a conversation
with him and said mate you're going to
be so important for this team you know
you're likely to be our starting seventh
for for the six nations
so
you do these one or two things for me
you're going to be there and that
immediately made him feel good so he
wanted to be part of the team
uh then for the other guys it's it's
giving them roles i think
is going to improve their rugby so
you're looking to each player quickly to
establish a personal relationship
trying to understand what what's the
important value for them in terms of
their sport and in terms of their
endeavor and then and then create that
link with them
so with the difficult ones you're
looking to either um bridge that gap or
get rid
and with the guys who are driven you're
trying to give them responsibility that
allows them to take ownership and move
forward
yeah and also show them how much you
care about them but the big thing about
about any team is that the players want
to know two things from the coach
firstly that they can improve them and
secondly that they care about them so
you've got to you've got to have the
knowledge of rugby particularly for
those driven guys
they want to know that you've got the
knowledge to take the team going forward
because they want to be part of the
successful team so you've got to quickly
assess in the team and i think you see
this in football all the time where
coaches are able to come in or manager
is able to come in a short period of
time and turn the team around they're
able to work out quickly how they can
improve the team and therefore how they
can improve the individual players
chances of being successful
so you've got to work out what that is
very very quickly and and for england it
was quite easy because
they've always been a strong defensive
and set piece team so i just focused on
what they were good at previously and
then gave them a picture of where we
could go potentially
it's interesting as a non-professional
athlete looking at these pros because
from our perspective these guys just
look like
titan athletic titans right just these
immovable objects that go on the pitch
and completely work to what the tactics
say that they're supposed to do but
you're right the only reason that a
manager or a coach is able to step into
a team whether it be football or rugby
and make a quick change they're not
changing the skills of the players the
players haven't acquired some new move
or something within the space of one day
or one week that this coach has been
there it's about the communication it's
about how they're framing that player's
role it's about how they're talking to
them it's about making them feel
comfortable confident secure within
their position within the team and
giving them responsibility to drive them
forward i've never thought of it like
that before but it makes so much sense
that's the only way you could turn
something around that quickly
yeah no 100 will you look at
i
yeah it's one of the most interesting
things for me is is watching how other
coaches operate
and having seen uh ran nick coming to
manchester united yeah every time he
talks he's very clear about what he
wants but
this is how the team's gonna play uh we
mightn't play like that now but this is
where we're going um he wants players
with a strong mentality
it doesn't matter how talented they are
they've got a strong mentality and you
can see you know every time he talks to
a media conference he's talking to his
players
so he's reinforcing you know we've set
about reinforcing the messages he's
constantly reinforcing the messages he'd
be telling him within the in the team
room he's saying that to the media so
they're hearing that right so we know
what this bloke wants
for us to be successful if we're going
to do this we've got to do these things
and at the same time i'm sure he gives
them
enough freedom to
to
to impose their own personality on the
team i reckon that's another important
point that
you know a team generally wants wants to
be like the personality of the coach
um
but at the same time the cages skill is
being able to
to not not
delete the player's personality from
from that so you want the players to be
themselves but you want to be part of a
group that plays like the cage wants to
play so they get on the same page but at
the same time for the players to be able
to have be their own personality
you see this in businesses as well right
the owner or the director or the ceo or
whatever
the culture is just a trickle-down
little microcosm of whatever it is that
they do in any case you see elements of
their personality borne out in the
company culture it is just like a little
projection of how that person operates
yeah 100 and then the individuals are
out able to add to that so they're
continuing adding but we had a sports
site come in
between 2018 and 2020 for the england
side and one of one of her great quotes
was that remember every conversation you
have with a player or with a staff
member you're either adding to the
business or you're taking away from the
business you never no conversation is
neutral and it's so so right that every
conversation you have whether it be
passing a guy in the hallway you can
either add to the team business that
what that day or take away from the team
business and your ability to to keep
adding to the business is the key thing
talking about james haskell you said
that he was an important part of uh like
lightening the dressing room up being
kind of the the life of the party so to
speak are there some other
support systems that a leader needs that
might not be so obvious at first you
wouldn't think that in a high-performing
sports team that having a life of the
party or someone that lightens the load
would be in there but it seems like it
was quite an important role
uh mate it's really important and again
it's that diversity of character that
you need so you not only need that in
the players but you also need a staff
member that's able to do that so we had
a guy called
scott wiseman who catch with me in japan
i brought him out of england for the
last two years like he was a sort of
like like honestly he's 50 now and he's
still got the same same pair of board
shorts he had when he was when he was 21
you know
and
they tell this story about new south
wales they're driving the training they
see this guy on the board shorts on the
skateboard you know with his cat
backwards pushing along his skateboard
going to training and this is the you
know one of the most important assistant
coaches so having a guy like that who's
good and he's good at his coaching but
also can add a bit of frivolity a bit of
humor like humor's such an important
thing in the sports environment um or
any competitive environment that you
have that balance between seriousness of
the job and that humor to to get people
to feel good about themselves
it's funny to think that a lot of a lot
of bad leaders that i've spent time with
they want other members of the team to
be exactly like them
but as you've said we're not going to
get that diversity through that way and
especially
whatever it is that you have having more
of that isn't what you need it's more of
the things that you don't have that are
then going to spread out that creativity
yeah yeah no that's right chris and i
think that the really important thing
there is as a leader or as a head coach
you need to know yourself you know
because when we're when we're a young
coach coming through yeah we think we
know everything and and we think we can
do everything and the longer your case
the more you realize know your strengths
coach would coach to your strengths and
then bring other people in that
compliment supplement and that add to
the team environment
i'm fascinated by the idea that the
coach can use
opportunities with the press as a chance
to communicate to the players
i think that that i mean you've had
some pretty advanced media strategies
over the last few years the way that you
went out and attacked the all blacks in
advance of your game with them and then
there was the sort of the v formation
that you guys formed around the hacker
can you explain sort of the plan behind
that that whole week
yeah well new zealand new zealand are
the darlings of world rugby you know
everyone loves them um and they should
because they're the most successful team
in the world so they've got and they've
got this mystique about them with the
black jersey doing the haka and having
lived in japan i know how much the
japanese love them um
so with uh
a guy that's worked with me for 20 years
now david pembroke is one of the
brightest people i know uh
he always at the start of the week will
send me some lines about where we think
we should go
so firstly we wanted
to put the new zealand media
on call that
uh
we wanted them to stir them up a bit
so they'd ask steve hanson who was the
head coach some questions so we came up
with that line of they're just fans with
keyboards to stir that up a bit and then
we wanted to wanted to make sure that
new zealand understood we were coming
after them so we used
we used some language at the start of
the week about how we're going to chase
him down the street and all these these
sort of things and the busiest person in
the new zealand camp would be the sports
psychologist who was you know well
renowned and one of the most successful
and then we had this idea right
that's that's all well and good but once
we get to the ground and they start the
haka the whole crowd gets enchants by
them
um and then they become the crowd
supports them so what we wanted to try
to do was get the crowd to think about
something else so came up with this idea
that
that we'd encircled the haka so we'd
make a circle around it but
that was the coach's idea so i gave it
to owen farrell the captain and i said
mate
this is my idea uh or our idea but then
you do you talk to the team and you do
what you think's right so they came up
with the idea that they'd make a v
um
and stay within the
distance i was supposed to stay which i
think you're not allowed over the
halfway line but unfortunately
we've got a blade called joe malu who
doesn't tend to listen to to most people
and he kept going so we ended up with
this you know this quite confrontational
v and you could hear the buzz in the
crowd you know all of a sudden well this
is not we're not here to just watch the
all blacks this is a this is a proper
game and it's on um so we we got that
right approach but yeah you do that in
other games and it doesn't work and you
look like an idiot mate
uh the video if anyone wants to go and
watch it on youtube you can see the
referee or the linesman sort of trying
to pull
joe marla back and saying no no you
can't you you're on this half of the
pitch you need to be in your half the
game hasn't even begun yet
but again you know that's that's a good
example of diversity because joe marla
like he's completely his own own man um
is he one of the most unique players
that you've coached
hundred percent mate but one of the best
players i've caged too like great team
man
really respected within the team but
yeah he's got his own way he wants to be
portrayed and we give him the freedom to
do that and as a result he keeps wanting
to play for england like he's retired
two or three times yeah he's got five
kids under 10 at home so he's got plenty
to do at home um
but he's a he's a great fellow great
fellow he's so entertaining to watch you
know he's it doesn't make it doesn't
surprise me that he's a fan favorite and
then when you find out that he's like a
player favorite too i guess haskell's
probably something similar right like
just that pure character it's um
it sets the it it gets you have to
forget or people sometimes forget when
we talk about high performance that
although sport is about winning and
about performing effectively it is an
entertainment i know that you've got
some problems at the moment to do with
the ball in ball out of play um time
which
although partly that's to do with how
the game's played in the dynamic it's
also to do with how enjoyable it is to
watch so if you've got a character on
the pitch with his crazy hair and his
like mad after match interviews and
there's things that the referee's mike
picks up as he's like joel is giving the
referee a slap on the arse or whatever
it might be like that's
that kind of makes for a spectacle that
people want to watch
and it goes back again you know you
don't want to be a nulling the the
player's personality you want them to
have their personality and and the
crowds want to see that they want to see
players with personality and you know as
professional sports got tighter and
tighter uh particularly i think it's
been harder for players to to be their
own person because
it's you know the academies want players
who behave themselves they don't want
players who are difficult who you know
want to do their own thing so those
players have to work really hard now to
come through
is there almost a sense of deprogramming
that when they get to the top level that
you go from being a a wild young kid you
need to show to the academy usually you
know if you've got some academy coach my
housemate's the ex-physio of the junior
academy at falcons and now the junior
first team and i think that
you know they want kids that show that
they can listen to discipline they want
kids that can do the thing but then you
get to the top flight and actually
you're now trying to bring you're almost
trying to deprogram that you're trying
to bring some of that individuality back
out again
yeah i think it's a it's a constant
battle um that we've got that that
we want players particularly i think in
the media to be there their own selves
we yeah
obviously there's a team line we want
them to follow but we want them to be
able to tell stories we want them to be
able to entertain the the people who who
pay you know ultimately the crowds pay
for for the players to play the game and
and they need to be able to entertain um
yeah i think that's just such an
important part of sport going forward
and you see
the american teams are probably best at
doing it aren't that you know i remember
seeing that cam newton for um i think he
played for carolina panthers you know a
real character the way he used to dress
coming to press conferences and people
remember that
did you watch uh
the last dance save glass dance the
michael jordan documentary on netflix
what were your thoughts about that
uh well again i reckon that's a great
example of a
coach
knowing what the team needed like when
rodman having rodman there with pippen
and jordan
he had the right balance in the team
when it was when jordan was out and it
was just pip pippen
and rodman rodman's force within the
team was probably too strong and there
wasn't enough
ballast in the senior player group to
to
to manage his idiosyncrasies
because if they were able to manage it
he was a force for the team but if they
weren't able to manage it then he became
a negative force for the team so i
thought that the way jackson was able to
manage that and you didn't hear much
from jackson in the in the
in the series but you could see his
influence on the team and
and
and the the way
the other bit i really liked was that
you know in nba it looks like in the
lead up to the finals it's all about
attack but as soon as you get to the
finals it's all about defense which is
is the same in most sports you know
what do you mean by that you could be a
good attacking team to get to the finals
but to win the finals you've got to be a
good defensive team
that's interesting i wouldn't have
thought that that would be the case
yeah or that the thing that stood out to
me how hard they played in defense in
the finals like jordan in the finals his
defense was incredible
and you think that you're going to see
the same or you do see the same pattern
come across into rugby as well
a hundred percent made certainly because
they're tight games you know and they're
50 50 games so the team that generally
makes the less heirs wins um yeah that's
an interesting one so what about
your habits for leadership what about
your routines and the non-negotiables
that you have in your daily existence
that make sure that you're performing as
well as you can as a leader
yeah i
think you've got to have a routine as a
leader
i certainly have developed that over the
years i've always had quite a strong
work ethic
so i've always worked long hours but
i've become much more effective in
working more effective hours
the book that i i read and got a lot out
of was a book called deep work by cal
newport which is about understanding
when your most profitable periods of the
day are make sure you do your hardest
work there
make sure you cut off all
all the distractions you have and do
your best work then the other periods
are more lighter periods of work so
that's that's really helped me a lot
that book and i was i was lucky enough
to have a zoom with him over any any
aspiring coach or any aspiring leader
should read that book yeah he's been on
the show about uh
a world without email which is his new
book that he is trying to turn people's
worlds upside down with there's one
thing actually i wanted to suggest that
you might really enjoy it's a book by
stephen kotler called the art of
impossible um so
you think about how someone like mihai
chiksek mihai or
cal newport they come at flow from quite
a psychological perspective
um
stephen comes at it from a biological
perspective so he looks at the
biological prerequisites
that cause a human to be in a flow state
um and that book okay
that book's really really impressive
there's something nice about having
someone that's like
spitting sawdust
uh around
what you need to do in order to prime
your body so it's a primer on peak
performance um but given your daily
routine which i know you tend to work on
a morning right you get a sort of
relatively early and then you crack it
out that aligns interestingly that
aligns really really closely with what
stephen talks about and he's done some
of the most advanced flow research on
the planet he owns the flow research
collective which is this big group and
blah blah blah and um it's funny how
people
that maybe don't know the neurology of
why it's happening they just arrive an
effective strategy simply by trial and
error
yeah now right that book right that's a
good tip good man good man so talk to me
about some of the new additions to your
team we've spoken about the fact that
we've got women on board and you've
touched on there's a media person you've
got a guy that used to speak to
psychopaths and stuff and you've got all
manner of different team members who are
some of the interesting new ones with uh
we've put on uh we use a forensic
psychologist now um and she used to
she used to assess psychopaths in in one
of the jails in in england and basically
to see whether they were going to kill
again
um and if they were going to kill they
had to stay in a high security jail
obviously if they they felt if she felt
they could move to a more
uh less secure or she tells the story
about how she'd sit in this
the room the jail room with these
psychopaths
having to having to try to analyze them
so we've got her on um to work with the
coaches so it's the first time we've had
a psychologist for the cage
oh so she's not just working sorry she's
not just working with the players you've
got her
working with the coaches to assess their
mental state as well she's working with
the coaches to to improve our
collaborative
um
improve our collaboration as a team and
also to improve our our language and our
communication just as we spoke about
before just the the power of language
now it's always been important but i
think it's even more important now so
she has uh her name's national
the
soul hem and she's written a book called
pin code and basically she's got
you know the approach of how you should
prepare for every conversation
your advance preparation
the way you use your body
and and the way you approach your
conversations just so important so she's
been she's been fantastic for us that's
interest i'm gonna steal that and i
might ask you for an intro to her once
we've finished as well
yeah that sounds really interesting um
it's still it's still fascinating me the
level of um
intricacy that you're seeing with rugby
i don't know how this compares with
other sports but like i say i've watched
my housemate from a front row seat move
through um the layers of you know a
top-level club and what one thing that
struck me from that is that there are
uh different groups and i imagine this
must be the same in most elite sports
but specifically within rugby um you
know he's part of the physio team but
the physio team needs to coordinate with
s and c
but snc also needs to coordinate with
coaches and everybody has their own
uh priorities so it feels to me like the
physio team are kind of erring on the
side of well look we know how long this
injury may take to come back the coach
wants the guy to be on the pitch the snc
person wants to deliver the player to
come back on the pitch so it makes sense
that coordination and communication
between you guys and really really
getting that right and not causing rifts
and politics within that coaching
community even before you even get to
the players it makes a lot of sense that
getting that right is is pretty crucial
oh it's absolutely crucial mate and it's
having that holistic approach to the
player that
there's you can't treat the player for
just one thing that everything's
connected you know so the their physical
state is
is
uh connected to their fitness level
which is connected to the ability to
play the game so we do a lot of case
studies some players and get all the all
the particular people involved making
sure that
that the approach we take to the the
player is the right approach and again
then it comes back to the language of
how you approach that um so the language
involved in that's just so important and
and because rugby's rugby is a
reasonably complex game
um that's not won by individuals it's
won by a team and that's why in rugby
you don't tend to get huge superstars
because it is it's the ultimate team
game like a messi in rugby would be hard
to
to to have because because he can't do
that without
everyone else doing their job because it
takes at least eight players to win the
ball before it gets delivered to him
there's no ben spence stokes on the
rugby pitch
but no there's not and it's difficult
difficult for those players to actually
survive in the game because it's such a
a complicated game and our job as a
staff is to make it simple you know
we've got to make this complicated game
simple for the players because we know
the new neurology of the brain if the
players are thinking all about this they
can't perform on the field so our job is
to make sure we keep that simple and the
communication between all those
departments has got to be so
concise and so much on the same page
because you imagine now a player comes
into a new player comes into a team yeah
we've got
22 staff members so they got now
established 22 relationships with 22
staff members yeah that's a hell of a
lot of work to do so if each of the
staff members telling them slightly
different thing then you can imagine how
confusion can come into a young player's
head so our ability to make sure that
the messages are clear and concise and
simple and and and driving the player to
the to the one goal um is just is just
massively important for us do you try
and restrict the number of people that
communicate sort of strategies and
tactics to the players in order to
reduce that uh degrees of freedom as
well 100 mate so we uh we've broken the
down broken the team down a little bit
like nfl uh that there's four groups of
players each have a
head coach so to speak for that group
and we want most of the communication to
go through that person
yeah particularly when the player's
going through a difficult stage we'll
try to channel all that information for
the right
person what about during half time or
you could imagine that this would be any
uh high pressure time sensitive
communication opportunity have you got
some principles that you go into that
with or that you tell the coaches to go
into that with are they trying to have
one thing that they'd speak about are
there some underlying rules yeah no most
most two things
at the most absolute most you know so
those old
you know
on any given sunday time speeches don't
happen anymore mate
it's one or two points um and we know
that the more stressed the player is
which they usually are at half time
they've got physical stress they might
have tactical stress
uh
that the ability to absorb information
is less so we need to keep that
information so concise so one or two
messages we're trying to get through at
the very most
nice what about when you notice in
yourself is there something that you
detect if your balance starts to go off
if you find yourself becoming less
effective or just that you're getting
you're straying away from the principles
is are there any um warning signs
that you find in yourself when that's
happening
uh well i i've deliberately put another
guy on a guy called neil craig who's
who's an afl coach um
previously in another life of sports
scientists so he's basically
he's a bit older than me um and he sits
there
next to me all the time in everything we
do and and keeps giving me feedback
about about what i'm doing um so that if
i'm do straying away if i'm doing too
hard or too soft or
not talking enough or talking too much
he's giving me that feedback so every
morning we'll have a coffee at half past
seven go through it and i heard another
story from a
australian friend of mine who catch the
the boomers at the last uh olympics and
they won their first medal ever and he
went and visited the milwaukee bucks
and he said
you know he had a good good relationship
with the head coach so he'd see that he
was there for 10 or 12 days he said
there's this little bloke every day
running around with this notepad
you know and and he didn't know what he
did because no one spoke to him
he didn't have no one introduced him
that he had a role anyway about the
ninth days there he said who is that
little black that's writing these things
down and the head coach says to him he's
the most important bloke in this in this
uh organization he says he writes down
everything i do well he writes down
everything i i don't
don't do well and at the end of the day
he gives it to me straight
and and you need someone in that the
organization to be doing that all the
time like it's like having a truth
teller there but someone who's who's not
afraid of of being absolutely honest to
make sure that they're picking up things
when you're moving away from what you
should be doing
it's like an external impartial
conscience
yeah
percent
yeah
what i mean
right the situations are so
highly charged and emotional especially
when you're getting toward game time
right we've got the world cup coming up
in less than less than two years now
your ability to judge your own
performance
and and remember what what you said and
what you did is basically zero like
you're the worst you're the worst
witness to your own mind but to have
someone there who's on your shoulder
what do you call that person is he the
coach's coach what is he uh well we just
call him craig
again he doesn't have a he doesn't have
a role mate but everyone knows what he
does okay
he keeps you in check because he's cause
he's seen as being neutral
he's also
acts as a source of
uh
that any of the players all the coaches
can talk to because he knows nothing
about rugby no it's absolutely zero
the best way you know
so they have very honest conversations
so he only not only access that for me
but he exit for for the coaches and some
of the senior players as well
what's this story about a samurai sword
and a kiwi
oh that was just like yeah because the
players have so many meetings we're
always trying to come up with novel ways
of of reinforcing the theme as we're
talking about so we had as we said with
the new zealanders we had that
we had that thing we're chasing we're
after them you know we're after them
this week they're not coming after us
we're going after them anyway i'm a half
japanese so i always wanted to have a
samurai sword i always thought of myself
as a samurai you know if i was born
700 years ago it would have been a
samurai i don't know how many fights i
would have lasted but anyway we're down
in miyazaki this tiny little coastal
town um
for a week and i asked the interpreter
who'd worked with me for a period of
time to go and try to buy me a samurai
saw so she traced around miyazaki and
found this tiny little shop and only one
person could go in the shop it was that
small and there was this
man in there about aged 80 and he'd been
collecting these samurai swords they had
this collection of samurai swords and
the one the one that that we bought um
was about
300 years old like we had the papers
that
said it was a legitimate samurai sword
so that was trent like that was like a
childhood dream to have that so i
thought now how am i going to use this
and i thought well we can't use we can't
use it on any of the players uh because
it might be a nasty cat so i thought i
will kiwi fruit so the night before i
got some kiwi fruit up in the room and i
was practicing chopping this kiwi food
so you know we've had the tweet meeting
gone through all the tactical stuff and
i said boys this what's gonna take we're
gonna we're gonna chase them down the
stream we've got to chop them in half
and just cut up some of the kiwi fruit
there's a bit of fun you know everyone's
laughing and
and you know everyone wants to see the
samurai sword afterwards so it's just a
way of of um
of reinforcing the message i want to see
the room service assistant that arrives
at your room with dinner that night as
you've got a samurai so this half
japanese man's got a samurai sword in
his like shorts and vest whacking seven
shades of [ __ ] out of a kiwi on his desk
yeah i'll probably get arrested mate i
wanted to bring the samurai sword back
to england but i think i'd get arrested
if i brought her back dangerous
dangerous weapon yeah i heard you say um
i was watching
one of the many uh eddie jones press
interviews uh compilations that exist on
youtube and you said i never worry about
things i can't control
how do you avoid being swept away in
those uncontrollable concerns and stuff
like that how do you notice when you're
getting outside of your domain of
competence and control
uh
again
uh a reflection is a big thing i think
yeah at the end of every day and i'm not
as deliberate as i should be
and i go through phases um but i'll try
to reflect very clearly on the day what
what i did well what i didn't do well
i've used like a high performance
journal there's about or i use just a
little book like this sometimes and i
just write things down and i try to be
as as deliberate as i can about
reflection each day and i think
yeah that's one of the most important
skills as a coach you need to have is
that ability to reflect uh record write
it down if you haven't done it well
write it down if you have done it well
again that reinforces the message that
of what you're not doing well or what
you are doing well so reflection is the
most important thing and that hubbard
seven coffee with uh neil craig's the
other one
talk to me about dealing with public
criticism
yeah when you're young it's hard mate
it's hard uh
when i was a young coach coming through
i felt
i felt all the criticism that was
that was
that was uh directed towards you when
you weren't doing well and i enjoyed the
praise when i was doing well and
probably uh
coming to coming to england really
helped me um i remember one of the first
lunches i had was with sir alex ferguson
i was lucky enough to meet him and he
said mate don't read any of it stop
reading it
and from that day onwards i haven't read
it so i really don't know i don't take i
don't
don't read it at all my wife might
mention something or my mama my mum's 96
lives in australia and she reads every
newspaper so she said they said this
about your mum i don't care i don't want
to know
um so i just don't take any any uh any
of it at heart at all so i don't even
read it so i don't even know so and
that's ignorance is your solution
yeah
yeah i think otherwise it's i think it's
so hard
that yeah i heard i heard a play the
other day i was watching a documentary
actually on australian swimming and the
the guy was saying he was a hundred
meter sprinter and he said you know he
reads social media he says there's 700
good comments and then there's one bad
comment and he says that one bad comment
sticks with him and he wants to ring
that person up and ask him why does he
say that
and and i think in in
in sport
if you have that sort of attitude it's
very difficult because you're wasting
time you're wasting time on that one
negative comment um that used to be
written on the toilet wall you know you
walk in the toilet someone say someone
had written on the wall so and so is the
so-and-so and all this sort of thing and
you know because you'd only be in there
for the toilet you you certainly go out
but now you know players have players
and coaches have to live with theirs
and then it becomes a
a storm and if you if you try to try to
at all rationalize what people try to do
that all you're doing is wasting time
how do you help the boys deal with
pressure you know we've got this big
world cup coming up there is some
expectation after a run of good form
recently
how are the especially the younger lads
that maybe don't have joe marla's five
attempted retirements and all of his all
of his experience
how do you help them deal with that
pressure
we want them to see it as a privilege
like it's a privilege of being part of a
good team that you're that you that the
precious air and the external pressure
is no greater than the pre
the expectation that's within the team
and the expectation that's within the
individual and one one of the things
we've started doing with the players is
coming up with a concept of a trademark
game
that we believe that
yeah a trademark game is a game
where
you play at the absolute minimum you
have to play but you play with absolute
effort and absolute control
now we reckon if if we have 75 percent
of our players playing at that because
that's that's hard to do
if we have 75 of our players playing at
that then we'll win we'll win most games
so we want the players to concentrate on
their effort and what they can control
rather than things they can't control so
it's again getting back to what can you
control in your performance control that
you can control your effort you can
control if you can control your emotion
you have to work on that so they're
practicing that trademark game each week
trying to trying to get brilliant at
that trademark game and if they can do
that then then the better games will
automatically come for them so they
don't have to aspire to be brilliant
every week because that's where i think
the pressure comes from
oh so you are allowing a release valve
you've got a realistic view of their
performance that it is going to
fluctuate from
the the absolute perfect to sometimes
below that and to say look it's okay
it's okay as long as you're playing with
effort and control
like there's a young player that we've
we just brought in i won't mention his
name
um
but he's he came in on the back of some
brilliance at club level came in and
played for england had a couple of games
and he was brilliant did some brilliant
things and now he keeps chasing that
brilliance
and rather than just chasing play play
play hard play control your emotions and
that will come sometimes other times it
won't come that you can play really well
and you can maybe not score goals but
you can play really well for your team
and help your team win but
because there's an expectation of your
scoring goals and then if you try to
score goals you're creating further
pressure on yourself rather than just
play hard for the team
like be the best player you can for the
team control your emotions control what
you can control and and ultimately those
better performances will come
that's such a really interesting way to
look at things to avoid
aiming for brilliance every single time
especially when it's not just you you
know you can maybe argue in a sport like
powerlifting where your opponent is the
bar and it's gravity the uh how would
you say the degrees of freedom have been
constrained right there's no there's no
opponent trying to punch you in the face
let's say in boxing or in sometimes in
rugby and
with that
having uh
having an approach of look your best
ever game isn't the standard that you
now need to try and beat that's just
where you can get to and what did you do
that got you there and we continue to
try and iterate on that
yeah and the best example in rugby
recently has been dan carter uh
who most of his games he was very solid
and then occasionally do one or two
brilliant things but people would harp
on about the brilliant things but it was
actually his brilliance was his
solidarity and that's you look at most
team sports that's what it's about it's
about being solid working hard then all
of a sudden you get the one opportunity
and if you're in the right place and at
the right time you get that opportunity
to do something brilliant
in england it seems like rugby is still
a private school dominated sport how
important do you think it is to have
players like ellis genji who are sort of
showing that whatever normal guys can
make it to the international level
uh very important mate because again you
know the diversity is important going
forward um and so we're so pleased we've
got guys like geng's guys like sinclair
have come through
they're not out of not out of the
pathway so to speak they've fought their
way through got you know i've had
previously guys like mark wilson who
went back to university to study yeah
those sort of players are really
important for us amazing eddie jones
ladies and gentlemen where should people
go if they want to find out more about
the book
uh well macmillan macmillan publishes
them and i'm sure they'll be at most
bookstores mate they'll be linked in the
show notes below eddie everyone will be
behind you over the next couple of years
i'm really looking forward to seeing
what the outcomes of all of this
these new psychologists and the person
that's looked at psychopaths and the guy
that's on your shoulder telling you when
you're getting it wrong i um
i really love to see
people
take
the minutia and the fine-tuned
fine-grained stuff right up to 11 we saw
this with team sky in the racing right
you know we saw what happens when you
really take a granular view and then you
deploy that to a to a team in a way that
makes sense so yeah man i'm uh i'm
confident going into 2023 all the best
look
uh good on you mate i really enjoyed
chatting to you i enjoyed your question
so all the best mate
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace